- To celebrate our season
three premiere this week,
we've been asking some
friends of the show,
here in LA, to share
their LA top three lists.
♪LA top 3♪
These are the off-the-beaten-path,
personalized picks
from people who have
lived in LA for years.
Today's top three comes from
one of our favorite guests
at the show, one of my favorites.
Let's head out to the literal field
where traffic anchor,
Robin Winston from our partner station,
NBC for Los Angeles has more
on this developing story.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, Kelly. It's so nice
to see you. And by the way,
I hope you had a decent
commute heading to work
this morning.
I know the LA traffic can be a little bit
of a headache sometimes,
but we're out here in some
little known bucolic pastors,
just outside of Los Angeles,
where it's absolutely beautiful.
It's so peaceful. It's so chill here.
Trust me,
when you get here, you're
not going to have to worry
about bumper to bumper traffic.
- And it looks like you're
at a ranch or something.
I want to go where you're at right now.
So will you introduce us to
the Secret Celebrity Selector
of today's LA top three lists?
- Absolutely. I'll give you a little hint.
She's one of the nicest
people in Hollywood,
I can vouch for that,
and you'll know her from
How I Met Your Mother.
It's Alyson Hannigan.
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- Hi. (clapping) I wanna
be where you are right now.
It looks awesome.
- You definitely want to be where I am.
- I do. How's your family?
- Good, how's yours?
- Oh, they're so good.
I'm so glad they're in
school. Amen. God bless.
Please keep them all in school. (laughs)
So Alison, you're giving
us your top three places to
entertain your kids in Los Angeles,
while you're really
tricking them into learning.
So what's number three?
- Okay. So number three
would be Underwood Farms,
which is like a big...
you can pick... a farm where
you can pick your own fruits or
vegetables or pumpkins around Halloween.
I really love that because it
just really teaches your kids
how the stuff that they have
in their lunchbox is grown.
So that's number three. Number
two would be Bob Baker's,
Marionette Puppet Theater,
which is such a wonderful experience,
especially for little
ones. And I'm so crafty.
I just really just
enjoyed the art department
and how they make these puppets.
And you learn so much about
all the history of puppetry.
And it's just wonderful.
But the number one is, where I am today,
The Gentle Barn,
where you can come and hug cows,
all of these beautiful, wonderful animals
have been rescued and
they're so well loved
and taken care of, and
you can just hug them.
And they're so lovely.
And then you'll just never want to leave.
- I love all your places.
Those were such great ones.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
It's always good to see you Alyson.
And you too, Robin.
Y'all have fun for me. I want to be there.
(audience cheering)